WE'LL SEE YOU THEN.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY,"
AN IMPORTANT MESSAGE FOR
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI WHO SEEMS TO
VALUE HAS PRECIOUS LITTLE EGO
MORE THAN YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
ALSO TONIGHT BIDEN'S BORDERS ARE
KAMALA HARRIS APPARENTLY
UNWILLING OR UNABLE TO DETERMINE
THE REAL CAUSES OF IMMIGRATION,
SO WE HAVE BEEN SENDING
SARA CARTER INTO CENTRAL AMERICA
WHERE SHE UNDER COVERED A
SHOCKING OPERATION.
AND WE HAVE THAT REPORT STRAIGHT
AHEAD.
BUT FIRST A BIG ANNOUNCEMENT
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE, A
BRAND-NEW GENEROUS HAND OUT TO
IVY LEAGUE GRADUATES, AND
WRAPPED UP MASSIVE STUDENT LOANS
AND NO LONGER FEEL LIKE PAYING
THEM BACK.
ISN'T THAT NICE?
NOW JOE BIDEN IS CALLING IT A
PROBLEM.
IT SHOULD BE A ACT OF 2022 ALL
PAID BY YOU THE HARDWORKING
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND TRUCK DRIVERS AND FARMERS
AND WELDERS AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY AND TAXPAYERS THAT
NEVER WENT TO COLLEGE OR NEVER
PAID OFF THEIR STUDENT LOANS.
MAYBE THEY WILL BE ON THE HOOK
FOR THE LOANS TAKEN OUT BY WHAT?
A HARVARD GRAD WHO MAGIC DEMAND
MAJORED IN GENDER STUDIES.
AND IT TOOK FROM THE RICH AND
GAVE IT TO THE POOR, BUT IN THE
WASHINGTON SWAMP HE TAKES FROM
THE POOR IN THE MIDDLE CLASS AND
IN ORDER TO BAIL OUT THE ELITES,
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING TO BE THE
FISHY AREAS HERE.
THIS MASSIVE $300 BILLION PAYOUT
IS GOING TO BE PAID FOR WITH
YOUR TAX DOLLARS OR GETTING MORE
TAX MONEY TO GET EVEN WORSE.
SO THIS FROM A GUY WHO CALLS
HIMSELF MIDDLE-CLASS JOE
ULTIMATELY DEMOCRATS, THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT THE MIDDLE CLASS OR
YOUR HARD WORK OR FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT PAYING OFF
THEIR WOKE BASE AND GUESS WHAT A
LITTLE OVER TWO MONTHS BEFORE AN
ELECTION.
IT DON'T TAKE MY WORD FOR IT,
JUST LISTEN TO THIS EXCHANGE
BETWEEN SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN
AND A CAMPAIGN EVENT IN 2020,
TAKE A LISTEN AT THIS.
>> I SAVED ALL MY MONEY, LOOKED
AT MY STUDENT LOANS, AND MY
GOING TO GET THROUGH?
SO WHO DID NOT SAVE ANY MONEY
AND ARE GOING TO GET SCREWED.
MY BUDDY HAD ON VACATION.
WE DID THE RIGHT THING WE GET
SCREWED.
>> Sean: WE DID THE RIGHT
THING AND WE GET SCREWED, PRETTY
MUCH RIGHT, AND WHEN CONFRONTED
WITH THE COLD HARD TRUTH,
ELIZABETH WARREN IS SPEECHLESS.
NOTHING EQUITABLE ABOUT THIS
HAND OUT.
AND BY THE WAY IT DOES ZERO TO
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSE OF
STUDENT DEBT.
FOR EXAMPLE, TUITION AT HARVARD
COST AROUND 55 GRAND A YEAR.
AND ALSO RECEIVES MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS FROM THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS ALONG WITH
MILLIONS MORE IN TAX-DEDUCTIBLE
DONATIONS.
AND TAKES IN SO MUCH EXCESS CASH
THAT IT HAS NOW ACCUMULATED A
$50 BILLION ENDOWMENT, AND NOT
JUST HARVARD, BUT ALL ACROSS
AMERICA ARE SWIMMING IN CASH AND
EVERY YEAR IT GOES UP AND UP AND
UP, OVER INFLATION.
AND BECAUSE OF EVERY STUDENT
LOAN, COLLEGES HAVE ZERO
INCENTIVE TO REDUCE COSTS OR
IMPLEMENT A BUDGET.
THEY ALWAYS GET PAID.
AND THIS HANDOUT IS NO
DIFFERENT.
THERE IS ONE GLARING PROBLEM
WITH THE JOE BIDEN'S ACADEMIC
PAYOUT.
ACCORDING TO
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI MAY BE FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN MY LIFE I
AGREE WITH HER, SHE SAYS THE
PRESIDENT HAS NO AUTHORITY AT
ALL WHATSOEVER TO FORGIVE LOANS.
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION, IT MAY BE
THE ONE TIME NANCY PELOSI WAS
RIGHT IN THE POLITICAL CAREER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PEOPLE THINK THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
HAS THE POWER FOR DEBT
FORGIVENESS.
HE DOES NOT.
HE CAN POSTPONE.
HE CAN DELAY, BUT HE DOES NOT
HAVE THAT POWER.
THAT HAS TO BE AN ACT OF
CONGRESS.
AND I DON'T EVEN LIKE TO CALL IT
FORGIVENESS, BECAUSE THAT
IMPLIES THAT A TRANSGRESSION --
IT DOES NOT HAVE TO BE FORGIVEN.
IT IS JUST FREEING PEOPLE FROM
THOSE OBLIGATIONS.
>> Sean: NO POWER FOR DEBTS,
WHAT DID HE SAY?
FORGIVENESS?
NO, NO POWER AT ALL.
THAT SHOULD BE CONGRESS' ROLE,
NANCY PELOSI FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN HER LIFE IS PROBABLY RIGHT
WITH JOE BIDEN'S LOAN SCHEME AS
IT EVER GOING TO SEE THE LIGHT
OF DAY?
I'M SURE THERE'S BEEN A CHANGE
OF POLITICAL H